so this really has to be seen to be
believed uh
fox host lou dobbs has been one of the
major
nodes of spreading bogus election fraud
claims since november 3rd he's done
everything from
interview that wacky lawyer sidney
powell to interviewing supposed
witnesses of voter fraud who
signed affidavits he's been full on with
this thing
repeating and allowing the promotion of
completely baseless claims about
companies like dominion voting and
smartmatic and others he's really been
full on with this thing
and then suddenly a couple of days ago
lou dobbs aired a fact check
that debunked his own election
conspiracy theories
what on earth is going on and what's
going on is fascinating it turns out
that smartmatic which is one of the
companies that makes voting machines
about which lou dobbs
has been spreading this information
smartmatic wrote a legal demand letter
to fox news
uh newsmax and oan threatening legal
action if they don't retract their
completely bogus claims about smartmatic
and the letter actually quotes lou dobbs
it quotes fox host maria bartoromo and
others
who simply will not stop making insane
claims about voter fraud
and it looks like fox lawyers decided
that the letters
had some teeth because lou dobbs ended
up airing the following segment
which please understand this key part
this
segment debunks the lies lou himself was
telling
over the last five weeks and lou just
looks
absolutely miserable introducing this
segment and what's fascinating
is that this is clearly a pre-produced
segment
meant specifically to get fox news out
of legal hot water
the questions are asked in voiceover
they're all very carefully worded
it's stunning to watch this take a look
lots of opinions about the integrity of
the election the irregularities of
mail-in
voting of election voting machines and
voting software
one of the companies is smartmatic and
we reached out to one of the leading
authorities on open source software for
elections
eddie perez for his insight and views
eddie is the global director of tech
development at the open source
election technology institute we asked
him for his assessment of smartmatic
and recent claims about the company
have you seen any evidence that
smartmatic software was used to flip
votes anywhere in the u.s in this
election
i have not seen any evidence that
smartmatic software was used to
delete change alter
anything related to vote tabulation
smartmatic says its software was never
used outside of la county in 2020.
do you know whether or not that's true
that is my understanding
smartmatic functioned as the contract
manufacturer
for the los angeles county voting system
and that was a customized system that
was effectively built to the county's
order
i am not aware of them having any other
direct customers relationships with
election officials in the united states
what about smartmatic and dominion do
you know if they're related
whether one owns the other whether
dominion uses smartmatic software
both dominion and smartmatic have
individually and respectively put out
very clear statements from their
corporate headquarters
each of them indicating they are
independent companies they are not
related to each other
it is my understanding that neither one
of them has an ownership stake in the
other
or anything like that so that directly
debunks the things
that lou dobbs and his guests have been
claiming
including as an example that there's
some kind of nefarious link
between smartmatic and dominion voting
systems
and then at the end of this segment they
just cut directly to commercial
no explanation no commentary from lou
dobbs
totally abrupt take a look and this is
right after debunking
another one of lou dobbs previous claims
says in which smartmatics technology was
banned in the u.s in 2020 due to
security weaknesses
or wrongdoing i am not i'm not aware of
any instances where smartmatics
technology was banned in the u.s again
it is
my understanding that outside of one
customer in los angeles county
smartmatic has no presence
in the voting technology marketplace in
the united states
[Music]
heading into retirement right to
commercial with uh with no word from lou
dobbs there
about how he has been making the
opposite claims
from that piece for about a month and a
half now
since the election so it seems very
clear
that this was an attempt by fox news
just to rectify the legal problem they
created for themselves by
airing this stuff for week after week
after week now
it's interesting it's not clear to me
that this is a huge win
you and i see this and we immediately
understand
they've been making false claims for
what five six seven
almost seven weeks at this point six
weeks at this point um
the claims have been completely baseless
and
once it became uh once it passed a
certain threshold
the companies about which the false
claims were being made got lawyers they
sent legal letters and fox recognizes
that they've got to issue some kind of
legal
uh they've got to do something here to
get themselves out of legal hot water
that's what you and i see when we see
this
unfortunately a lot of fox news viewers
won't understand or even if they do
understand
that they are not going to believe or
give that segment credibility
uh they give what lou dobbs has been
doing the last six weeks credibility but
not that segment
the saying is something like everybody
sees the headline
and nobody sees the correction uh one
week later
on the back page of the paper that's
basically what this is what this is
lou dobbs aired lies that he likely knew
were lies for the last six weeks
they got a legal demand letter from
smartmatic we know that's true
and we are inferring that that's why
that segment was aired
again without any commentary from lou
dobbs or him saying i've been one of the
people
telling you the lies for the last
however many weeks
maybe that is enough for fox news to get
out of legal trouble
but the viewers aren't going to be
convinced by it the viewers are going to
say
what lou dobbs has been saying for six
weeks is true i don't even know what
that segment's about i tuned out
once once it get cut away from lou i
thought it was a commercial i walked
away
and and grabbed a drink in the kitchen i
don't know if you guys remember
but back in 2005 dan rather on cbs news
aired some improperly sourced documents
about george w bush's national guard
service
and uh it turns out that the documents
they used
were not accurate and four cbs
executives
were fired for that and dan rather
resigned over that mistake fox news
oan newsmax won't stop repeating
the same baseless lies about the
election
and the penalty is that lou dobbs aired
a two-minute pre-produced fact check
without even acknowledging that he was
one of the
nodes of spreading the disinformation
that that very segment was debunking
even in the last 10 years the downfall
of seriousness in media has been
absolutely stunning
and is it better that lou dobbs aired it
than
not airing it all else being equal given
the fact that he's been spreading the
lies is it better that he aired it yeah
sure
the reason he aired it though is not to
provide an alternative point of view one
that's fact-based
it's because they got a legal demand
letter and it's absolutely pathetic